the ACMs are coming up such a you know
joyous exciting time but I imagine for
you there's got to be a lot of mixed
emotions with going back to Vegas yeah a
little bit I mean I'm looking forward to
going to Vegas and you know obviously I
think every time I I go to Vegas from
here on out you know it'll be a little
bit different Jason Aldean opens up
about returning to Las Vegas for his
first performance since October when a
gunman opened fire during his set at the
route 91 Harvest Festival just a little
bit of a weird feeling but I think you
know I've experienced a lot of great
things out there a lot of big times in
my career really career defining moments
for me in Vegas so I love the city I
love going out there I'm excited to go
to the ACMs and I'm excited that it's
you know that I'm going out there with
the country music family you know that
I'm gonna be surrounded by a lot of
people out there friends and just people
in the business that a lot of them were
there you know a lot of them were there
that weekend playing on that same
festival so I think for me to go back in
this you know in this way with all those
people I think is kind of the perfect
way to really go back and and do it for
the first time I think I imagine there's
gonna be a lot of hugs going around I'm
out of carpet probably probably so yeah
can you tell us what else you have
planned while you're in town
I'm gonna go try and see Timberlake he's
playing out there so I'm gonna go try
and see his show I've never seen him
laugh so I got my sisters out my wife's
coming out and we got some friends out
so we just kind of wanted to get out one
night and go check out this show usually
at some point out you know a bunch of us
a lot of my friends will get together me
and Luke Braun Darius Rucker Charles
Kelly all of us will kind of get
together and get a table and just kind
of spend one whole night doing nothing
but gambling and kind of hanging out so
that's always one of my one of my
favorite things to do while I'm there